>> All right Charles, so, so, what do you think the answer is here?
>> Actually I don't know what you're looking for here.
>> Oh, okay. Well, so one thing that's true. We
had to sample the, the variables from A to E.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And that's alphabetical order. So do
you think that's what I was looking for?
>> Maybe in this case but I would think that that wouldn't be generally true.
>> True. Right. So, yeah, alphabetical is not what I
was looking for. So, there's it's a graph theoretic property
that says we want to basically put the nodes
in order, so that you always put the things
that have incoming links that haven't been visited yet
after the ones where you, they have been visited.
>> Oh, so it is a lot like alphabetical
or a lot like lexo-, lexicographic, but it's topological.
>> There we go. Yeah, that's what I was looking for. So, topological sort.
>> Which makes perfect sense.
>> Right, and so this a standard thing that you can do with a graph, and it's
very quick to, to actually compute one of
these. It does depend on a particular property, though.
>> Let's see. Topological only makes sense if you really can
go from no parents to parents. So, it cannot be cyclical. You
can't have arrows that take you back. So, E can't be a
parent of A and also have A be one of its parents.
>> That's right.
>> So it must be acyclic.
>> Must be acyclic, right. And that's going to
be true in these cases, because we're always going
to set it up so that in a, in a Bayes net, the variable that we're each
variable depends on other variables. But they all, it ultimately has to bottom
out. There can't by cyclic dependencies. So, it is a directed acyclic graph.
>> So, what would it mean if there were cycles?
>> I don't know. I don't know what to do with such a graph.
>> It just doesn't mean anything at all, I guess.
>> Yeah, I mean, there, there is a family of undirected models.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But we're talking only about the directed ones here. So, the directed
ones yeah, it'd have to be acyclic for the, for the probability distribution
to be meaningful.
>> Well, that makes sense.
>> I'm sure we could make something up, but this is, typically
this is how it's done. It's, it's, we constrain ourselves to acyclic graphs.
>> Well, if a Bayesian network is
supposed to capture conditional independencies, then if you
add cycles, that's like saying there are none,
right? I'm not even sure what that means.
>> I could make it mean something. So here,
we, we want the probability of A, conditioned on probability
of A. Well, maybe that's like probability of what, what A was one time step
ago. Or it could mean that it, you
know, that, that we've actually putting constraints on
the joint assignment to all the variables.
But, yeah, it's not really, it doesn't really,
it makes things more complicated and that's not
he model that, that is the typical one
>> Okay, fair enough.